i
gracias por acompañarme una semana más
en medioambiente de france 24 hoy nos
centramos en españa concretamente en la
región de murcia al sureste de la
península ibérica' allí se encuentra el
mar menor' una de las mayores lagunas
saladas del continente europeo con una
área de 170 kilómetros cuadrados está
separada del mar mediterráneo por la
manga una franja de tierra de 22
kilómetros de largo lo que durante
décadas fue un lugar de aguas
cristalinas humedales y alta
biodiversidad tanto de aves como de
especies acuáticas es desde hace varios
años una sopa verde en la que cada
cierto tiempo mueren millones de peces
crustáceos y plantas marinas en 2016 se
vio una primera oleada de muerte seguida
por otra en 2019 el último y peor
episodio se dio a mediados de agosto de
este año más de 10 toneladas de peces
muertos o moribundos fueron recogidos de
la orilla del mar menor' en pocos días
pedro luengo coordinador de la
organización ecologistas en acción de la
región de murcia nos explicó qué le está
pasando a esta laguna española tiene un
desequilibrio muy grande está en un
proceso que se conoce eutrofización que
es pues un exceso
demasiada llegada de nutrientes a este
ecosistema que básicamente son sobre
todo fertilizantes agrícolas de la
cuenca que vierte al mar menor y que
puede estar provocando crecimientos de
algas que a su vez desencadenan unas
reacciones que entre otras cosas pues
acaban matando todo lo que son las
praderas subacuáticas y genera momentos
en los que hay falta de oxígeno en
algunas zonas normalmente en aguas más
profundas y esto provoca mortandad de
peces como decía luego la gran parte de
estos nutrientes proviene de
fertilizantes de los cultivos agrícolas
de la región una zona conocida como la
huerta de europa porque murcia exporta
el 24 por ciento de las hortalizas y el
16 por ciento de las frutas frescas de
toda españa' en su gran mayoría hacia
europa mucho de este cultivo se da en el
llamado campo de cartagena
de unas 60.000 hectáreas que hace unas
décadas era de secano es decir un tipo
de agricultura que solo utiliza el agua
de lluvia para su riego pero desde los
años 70 se hizo un cambio en el tipo de
cultivo hacia el regadío que en esta
región requiere de fertilizantes para la
tierra y de agua traída de otros lugares
agua que una vez sale de estos cultivos
a rastras restos de químicos y
sedimentos que terminan por desembocar
en la laguna a raíz de este evento y
tras recibir presión de ecologistas y
del ejecutivo de españa el gobierno
regional de murcia ha prohibido el uso
de fertilizantes nitrogenados
inorgánicos en la llamada zona 1 que
incluye los primeros 1500 metros desde
la orilla del mar menor' una medida que
desde ecologistas en acción reciben con
cautela ya que ellos insisten en que la
solución es reducir el número de
cultivos ilegales además de implementar
otras soluciones naturales la solución
que pasa por reducir la cantidad de
superficie en regadío
empezando por
aparte que son radios ilegales de esas
60.000 hectáreas que son más o menos en
función del momento después hay unas
10.000 que son ilegales reconocidas que
tienen expedientes abiertos pero que
todavía siguen funcionando curiosamente
y luego pues hay que intentar
reconvertir otra parte más de las que
son legales pero para reducir la
cantidad de este regadío porque así
reducimos la cantidad de aporte de
fertilizantes que se realizan en el área
del mar menor y luego hay que hacer una
serie de barreras que capturen los
abonos antes de que lleguen al mar
menor' a distintos niveles a nivel de
parcela agraria a nivel de áreas un poco
más grandes y ya una barrera que
llamamos el cinturón verde alrededor del
mar menor en lo que es la parte más
cercana a la masa de agua que tendría
pues un kilómetro y medio dos kilómetros
de barrera vegetal que iría filtrando el
agua que le llega y absorbiendo esos
nutrientes y el agua ya llegaría sin
nutrientes y sin sedimentos o con muy
poco hasta lo que es el mar menor
algunas asociaciones de agricultores
tratan de evadir responsabilidades
mientras que otras como para la
organización de pequeños y medianos y
ganaderos de murcia se muestra
preocupada y pide que no se use al
sector como chivo expiatorio
siempre hemos dicho que si en el origen
fuimos parte del problema queremos
también ser parte de la solución
reclamamos respeto y apoyo para las
explotaciones familiares lo que es
compatible con la crítica a las malas
prácticas y las exigencias a otros
sectores económicos y actividades que
también deben ser parte de la solución
también exigen a las autoridades locales
regionales y nacionales que reviertan
décadas de inacción con respecto a la
salud del mar menor' algo con lo que
coincide pedro luengo hay que conseguir
que las actividades económicas de las
que viven familias y que son necesarias
pues se hagan de forma que sean
realmente sostenibles y no solamente en
el papel que sea algo que realmente se
reduzcan los impactos y se evite que
esas actividades generen unos daños
irreparables en el medio ambiente que
ponen en jaque no solamente
el propio ecosistema sino la vida que
hay alrededor incluso del propio ser
humano si el mal menor acaba siendo una
ciénaga y un mar muerto mucha de la
actividad económica y social que hay
ahora mismo alrededor de la laguna se va
a perder va a tener que emigrar a otro
sitio y esto pues es una consecuencia
muy indeseable este fenómeno no es
exclusivo del mar menor' sino que lo
hemos estado viendo desde hace años
sobre todo en la costa caribeña de
méxico con la llegada del sargazo un
alga que también crece y se reproduce
gracias a la presencia de nutrientes en
las aguas provenientes de la
contaminación por actividades humanas es
todo por esta semana nos vemos la
próxima
[Música]